okay i'm going to take the next two
checklist questions i'm going to bundle
them together the first is checklist
item number 42 do you know when to make
your first hire checklist item number 43
do you know what positions to hire for
first
so
you have to in the marketplace
get somebody
to quit
their job and come work for a startup
that is high risk
this is not an easy task so let's assume
you have three co-founders right you're
gonna have to assess well what do the
three of you do really well and are
there any glaring uh holes in your team
so let's say you have two developers and
somebody who is a great sales executive
who's doing the fundraising and they're
the ceo
uh and one person's the cto and the
other person is the president
and what are you missing
maybe you're missing a designer somebody
who's great at ux maybe you're missing
somebody who's great at customer support
customer happiness you're gonna have to
look
and decide
who is the best person to help it might
be just another developer it might be a
sales executive because you have a great
product and you need more people to sell
it so
it's also going to cost money so you
might want to get the product to the
point in which you've raised money or
you have your first two or three
customers and you've got a little bit of
money coming in because what you don't
want is to have
that person sitting there doing nothing
or you don't want to hire somebody for
so far below market that they quit
and so it's can be a difficult thing to
figure out once you've raised money well
then you should start thinking about hey
where do we need to be in 18 months
hopefully you've raised 18 months of
runway where do we need to be between 12
and 18 months when we start the
fundraising process again will we be at
break even and we don't need to raise
money or profitability will we be
burning 50k a month but have 10
customers who are spending 10 dollars a
year with us
you want to really do a little bit of a
plan there and the plan will then
dictate what you need so if you're
trying to get to ten thousand a month
and reoccurring revenue a thousand
dollars a month per customer ten
customers well you need to sell those 10
customers well you need to have two
sales people if your sales people sell
one person every two months or you're
gonna need one person if they sell one
person a month you get the idea
and so let's move on to checklist point
number 43 do you know what positions to
hire for first okay we've talked about
that first higher you really want to get
somebody who is
filling in basically for the fourth
founder position or the third founder
position and who's going to move the
ball forward
now once you've raised money
now you have to start thinking about
what positions you're going to hire
first
sometimes you're going to need to hire a
lot of people in one group
if you are an ai company and you're
doing machine learning going to take two
or three people right so you may need to
hire them before you do anything else
because your pre-product market fit
and you cannot get the product complete
without those three and you're gonna
need to think about well when are you
gonna start the sales process in the
marketing process one of the most
frustrating thing for sales and
marketing people is to come to a company
before they have product market fit
before they finish the product because
they're going to sit there twiddling
their thumbs what do i do write
marketing materials what do i do create
ad creative when we haven't finished the
product it's incredibly frustrating
same thing would be true for a customer
support rep well if there's no customers
what's the rep going to do be very
careful to not hire too early
conversely
if you've got the sales team out there
selling and you don't have customer
success and customer support in yet you
are quickly going to be faced with
churning customers
this is where a plan comes into place
if you make a plan for how many
customers you're going to have how many
you're going to add each month
well you've set a target i want to add
two customers a month okay our sales
executives can land 10 meetings a week
at scale
but they ramp up to that so let's just
put it at 20 we'll cut it in half
they're gonna do five meetings one a day
we think that's what we can book okay we
know that every 20 results in one sale
so we need two sales people over time
rate sales people become more efficient
maybe they'll get 30 meetings and
therefore they'll start signing
one or two customers a month okay great
so you can kind of model that you also
know that sales people turn over quickly
because in a lot of cases
they might not be missionaries they
might be mercenaries uh and so you might
expect a little bit of a higher turnover
rate therefore you're going to say for
every three sales executives we expect
one to not make it past three to six
months therefore our hiring plan is to
hire
six sales people to get to four
and if we happen to get to six we'll be
delighted that means we have to hire one
every month for six months so that in
month seven we have four up and running
landing two customers if we are in fact
landing two customers each and we have
eight coming in a month we're gonna hit
this amount of revenue and we're gonna
need ballpark
you know one customer success person for
every
you know
10 new customers a month great and we're
going to need to have a customer support
rep you get the idea you're going to
really want to think through a plan and
when you have a plan like that
the goals you set in the plan will
determine
the
uh resources needed in other words the
human resources needed the positions
needed some you can outsource
most of them you cannot
accounting you can legally you can
hr you can
but sales you can't uh so keep that in
mind you if you can
outsource certainly accounting legal
are always and human resources are
almost universally today outsourced in
the first two years
okay
when you're starting out
people tend to hire generalists and then
specialists what do i mean by this the
first five employees at a company tend
to do three four five jobs each
then over time you get to 50 employees
and those 30 skills
you tend to have one or two or three
people working on each one what's an
example well when you're starting out
you might have an operations person they
might do hr
they
might do the accounting they might do
legal they might do fundraising
and they might manage the office if you
had an office and they might also do i.t
company hit scale you tend to have an
i.t manager an hr department with three
people in it you'll have an accounting
firm maybe an internal bookkeeper you
get the idea if you're ambitious it's
great to be an early employee at a
company because the generalists
get to do so many jobs however if you do
not quickly become a specialist
you will get replaced by a specialist
that's why you see some people
who do four years at companies and then
go to another startup why they like the
zero to one
function going from no product to having
a launch product from no customers to a
customer and that's okay those
generalists are awesome in the world
but
they tend not to be specialists they may
not like to do one thing 50 hours a week
which is what you need at scale
okay so
uh what do you need early you really
need developers and product managers
early what don't you need hr lawyers pr
that stuff comes later and you can
outsource that stuff
keep in mind the bar raiser hiring
process at amazon every person you hire
should be better than 50 percent of
those in similar roles
basically the concept of hiring is
you know if you have the resources you
want to hire people who you can learn
from as the founder so i always try to
hire sales executives or operational
people who have done more of that than
me now i'm 50 years old i've done a lot
of this stuff so the chances of as you
get older and wiser and you got more
scar tissue and you've done it multiple
times the chances of having somebody you
can learn from
as in a higher goes down but i still
find them and it's really great when i
do
so hire those bar raisers especially if
you're a first-time founder and when i
was a first-time founder i had carol
martesco elliott cook a lot of people
around me who knew much more than i did
about running companies joanne wilson
they and they basically were able to
pull me up and say hey schmuck
here's how this works and i say oh
thanks i had no idea what the difference
between accrual and cash-based
accounting was and they had been through
that 10 times and they're like do this
do this do this i was like okay i'll
just listen to them and it was great for
me